hey guys how's it going this is Vlog
University and we're in Miami
B so got a little bone to pick with
everyone in the world especially here in
Miami because that's pretty much all
anyone ever says and they think it's
funny like we're in Miami we know where
we are we know so please stop singing
the song and stop calling me the b word
okay thanks on to the show and last
week's episode your homework assigned
was synchronized so if you guys don't
know what synchronized is you should
probably Google it before you submit
videos of things they're not
synchronized but some of you guys well
you got it you kind of took a little
spin on the word you got a synchronized
watch you've got synchronized
snacking synchronized
gymnastics synchronized
dancing
and I don't even care if this has
anything to do with being synchronized
because I love puppies
okay and now this is just beautiful and
peaceful and
Serene that's all the videos that we
have for this week next week your
homework assignment slsh showand tell
challenge is escape so make a video post
it as a video response here and be sure
to share it on Escape Route
under challenges and submit it under
showand tell for a chance to win cool
prizes so make a cool video get out
there and Escape something but be safe
cuz I know some of you guys don't get
too crazy okay okay I'm going to get
back to being in Miami
B